here's what happened when I was working
on Saturday Night Live with Albert
Brooks it was the late 70s and I was
always a fan of music a big fan of rock
and roll and just then that whole punk
rock movement started happening and I
started going out and seeing all the
bands and going to the clubs and under
striding to understand this movement
which to me was very very radical music
movement but also radical social
movement and I and I really think about
myself I didn't really consciously say
it back then but today I think about
myself as kind of a rock and roll
anthropologist and I I wanted to learn
more about the the punk rock scene and
all the guys I was working with when I
was hanging out with Albert
you know like Rob Reiner and Oh James
Brooks and you know a lot of really
high-profile comedians they said they
you know
Penelope go on an interview you maybe
you could produce this movie Private
Benjamin that Goldie Hawn is doing and I
said no I think I'm not even going to go
on that interview because I had just
produced real life Albert Brooks first
feature I said now I'm not even gonna go
on that interview because I want to make
a documentary on punk rock music and
they all thought I was crazy and matter
of fact they they harassed me a lot
about it but I went and did it anyway
and it was really it was the decline of
Western civilization is the first
feature I did and it was some people say
the most written about movie of that
year which would have been 1981 when it
was released and everyone was writing
about that movie because they didn't
understand the movement all the critics
all the reviewers they just had to
understand it and know it and see it and
try to figure it out so it really put me
on the map as a director now the thing
about doing the decline of Western
civilization which to me that was the
point in my career what I decided I'm
not going to be a producer I'm going to
be a director I I to this day and so
thankful that I made that decision
because making movies is all
about changing people's lives and so
many people over the years have come to
me and said thank you for making the
decline of Western civilization series
there's three films now because it
changed my life it made me think
differently about the world it made me
move out here from you know Hoboken or
you know it made a big difference in a
lot of people's lives and if there's any
real one reason for making a movie it's
if you can change people's lives
you